[Music]
the wait is almost over for Kim
Kardashian to tell all about being
robbed at gunpoint in Paris now Keeping
Up with the Kardashians has been
promoting this for ever and it's finally
happening this Sunday they definitely
were watching psy turn the lights off
and went upstairs
this new clip comes nearly ten weeks
after investigators charged ten people
in connection with the October heist of
more than five million dollars worth of
Kim's jewelry there is probably a group
of guys that were following us the
entire trip but some online commenters
are taking aim at the show's continued
teasing of Kim's traumatic story as a
ploy for ratings that's when I saw the
gun like clear as day over the course of
last season you ership dropped by half
and Ichi has learned this upcoming
episode won't be the only one focusing
on the robbery it will play out through
several episodes we started filming
Ozma's on Ellen Kris Jenner defended her
daughter's decision to film after the
incident what was coming out of that was
very therapeutic for her I think to just
explain to us and walk us through
well Kim did take a three-month social
media break following her scare her self
promotion is back on this past weekend
she plugged her show's season premiere
while presenting keeping ups executive
producer with an award Sunday on e Kim
notes how costly posting her whereabouts
can have consequences
I was snapchatting that I was home and
that everyone was going out so I think
they knew that I was there by myself
they had this window of opportunity and
just went for it
[Music]
you